so republicans have blocked even
debating and discussing
this major voting rights bill that we've
been talking about now
for quite some time and we are really
now getting into
sort of the most disgusting and
destructive of american politics and of
course
huge blame goes directly to the
republicans
who voted against even debating the
voting rights bill
but also we can't ignore the fact that
the great negotiation
that uh joe biden has claimed he would
be able to do
has not even led to a debate about
the voting rights bill and we're going
to have video from the floor of the
senate uh
and and much more and in fact maybe
we'll even uh start there
this is the uh moment where
uh kamal harris who presided over the
senate during this vote
um announced that uh the bill was uh
it wasn't we were not moving forward
into debate take a look at this
the a's are 50 the nays are 50.
three-fifths
of the senators duly chosen and sworn
not having voted in the affirmative the
motion
is not agreed to now what you have to
understand
when you um evaluate this
is that there really are two completely
different realities
on this issue mitch mcconnell for
example
came out and said we don't even really
have a voting rights issue in this
country
there aren't even people trying to
suppress
the ability of individuals to vote he
said this i guess with what what for
mitch mcconnell counts
as a straight face let's take a look at
what mitch mcconnell had to say i mean
how do you say this with a straight face
how do you have the uh gumption and uh
i mean the tolerance for cringe to come
out and say the following
and many of you have written about the
subject of big lies
well the big biggest lie being told in
american
politics in recent weeks has been that
the states are involved in a systematic
effort
to suppress the vote that's just a
why why would anyone think that that's
going on i mean other than the fact that
republicans have been openly admitting
it since
at least 2012 when mike terzai said
voter id is going to make it
so that mitt romney wins pennsylvania
and then everything else that happened
in the nine years that followed
and the 250-something bills across the
country
those arguments are being made by people
who obviously haven't read any of these
new state laws
because that's not happening as we all
know we had the biggest turnout
uh last year since 1900. now that's a
red herring
that's a complete and total biggest
turnout since 1900 how many people lived
in the united states in 1900 so
the there's three or four different
reasons why that's not a good argument
number one as the population continues
to get larger and larger
you would expect more and more people to
vote trump often points to hey i got 75
million votes he really got 74.
uh that you know that that makes it hard
to believe that i lost given that 74
million people voted for me well even
more people voted for joe biden
and in addition to that we don't know
how many people wanted to vote
so it's just a complete and total red
herring let's just look at a little bit
more of this
there is no effort in any state in
america
to suppress uh votes based upon
um suppression of
minority uh participation so that's a
complete and total
lie i mean it couldn't be it couldn't be
a more dishonest thing to say so let's
look at a little bit of the reporting
about this
cnn reporting senate republicans block
signature democratic election bill in
key
test vote saying that senate democrats
suffered a loss when republican
opposition
sunk their signature voting and election
bill during a key test vote
underscoring the limits of the party's
power with the narrowest possible senate
majority
a procedural vote to open debate was
defeated by 50 50
falling short of the 60 votes needed
democrats were united in favor after
securing joe manchin support but
republicans were united against it
causing the measure to fail to
advance democratic senators have pitched
the legislation as a necessary counter
to state-level efforts to restrict
voting access
republicans have decried it as a
partisan power grab
and a federal overreach into state
voting
and election systems the article goes on
to say senate democrats are already
beginning
to map out their next steps to draw
attention to the issue and put the focus
on a critical battleground state
georgia now one of the lies that they
are already telling
about georgia is hey listen voter
purges are normal this is one of the
techniques
or tactics that is being used by
republicans
to hurt democrats in elections and it is
to purge voter rolls but to say
every state does it now it's true that
every state does it
but with far less restrictive barometers
than what georgia is putting in place
and so you really have to look at the
details and this is one of those issues
where
if you're not following it relatively
closely
you're not going to understand why the
bullet points
from republicans fall short and this
everybody does it one
is is uh really a um an important
example an illuminating example which is
they insist every state has a system for
deciding
who should no longer be considered an
active registered
voter and it depends on how recently
you have voted and other factors what's
being done in georgia is far more
aggressive and it's being done
in a very tailored way that while in an
overt way it doesn't target minority
voters it's
focused on those more likely to be
voting for democrats
who happen to disproportionately be
non-white voters so i get it people are
busy people are working people have
lives
so unless you're following it closely
you would not necessarily understand why
the claims that are being made are so
deceptive now i want to talk about one
other thing here
which is the filibuster aspect of this
there is a good article in the la times
an editorial by the times editorial
board which says
senate republicans won't even consider
voting rights the filibuster must go
and it makes sense that there is
increased pressure
to do away with or modify the filibuster
because it's not even that they're
voting against the bill they're voting
against debating the bill and you need
60 vote votes in order to move forward
they wrote yesterday as expected debate
on a bill to protect voting rights was
blocked in the senate
when democratic sponsors failed to
garner 60 votes
but in reaching out to centrist joe
manchin democrats indicated they were
open to compromise
the shameful reaction of senate
republicans on the other hand
demonstrated that they are willing to
ignore laws
approved by republican-controlled
legislatures that make voting harder
those measures reflect the lingering
malign influence of donald trump's big
lie
that the 2020 election was stolen
they go on to say uh about the
filibuster
and i want to find the exact point where
that is
um after tuesday's vote schumer
said that it represented the starting
gun
not the finish line mansion and other
and another democratic senator kirsten
cinema of arizona
have resisted the idea of abolishing the
filibuster but if republican senators
continue to stone while reasonable
legislation
to protect the right to vote those two
reluctant democrats
must be pressed to recognize that at
least we're protecting democracy is
concerned
the filibuster must go and this is
absolutely and totally correct now
whether the filibuster must go in total
which potentially is going to have
repercussions
against democrats when republicans
invariably
take control again um at least
in practical terms you either need to
reform it to require a talking
filibuster
you either need to require the 40 no
votes to be in the senate at all times
in order to continue
something absolutely has to be done i
think at this point
it's been clear you know if republicans
and democrats
were equal in their willingness
to do whatever needs to be done to move
a bill forward
then maybe we wouldn't be having this
conversation but democrats have shown
that they are not willing to do what
needs to be done
in the way that republicans are to get
moving forward
on legislation that they claim is
important to them so something is going
to have to be done
to the filibuster it absolutely is time
and again
if republicans said we believe we have a
really strong case
why this bill should not pass and we
plan not to support it but let's debate
the bill
and then make their case against the
bill during the debate i would have a
different perspective
but they're saying no to even debating
the bill something has to be done
and the filibuster is going to have to
be a big piece of that
do not forget that one of the best ways
to support the david pakman show is by
supporting our awesome
sponsors and today one of those sponsors
is sheath
underwear the weather is warming up it's
hotter
it's stickier out there and
unfortunately for many of us that comes
with a lot of sticking and rubbing and
chafing
with traditional underwear that is what
sheath underwear has solved sheath has
developed
unique boxer briefs with multiple
ergonomic
compartments in the front preventing
skin on skin contact that means
everything stays separate dry cool and
comfortable
with sheath underwear there is no more
sweating no more chafing
no more readjusting it's great sheath
underwear is giving the david pakman
show audience 20
off when you go to sheath underwear.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman
give sheath underwear a try
my experience has been great i believe
yours will be as well
you can find the link underneath this
video and do not forget to use that
promo code pacman
for 20 off